foreign
[Music]
yeah Miss Jackson showing us what it
really means to be flexible if anybody
can do it you just have to want it the
56 year old singer is getting ready to
headline Essence annual music festival
in New Orleans and she's taking fans
behind the scenes of her dance
rehearsals which include showing off her
impressive stretch routine
everybody
[Music]
at one point Janet pulls her leg into a
heel stretch while a group of backup
dancers goes over their moves in the
background she then pulls the full heel
stretch while laying flat on her back
practically going into a split
[Music]
yeah totally making it look easy right
and of course the comment section filled
up with praise and awe for the
jaw-dropping moves Kelly Rowland wrote
stretching every day from now on and one
fan tweeted she is flexible while
another question how she more than
double my age and makes me feel like I'm
the one that needs to retire I'm very
happy after reminding us all of how
limber she is Janet then shared the
dance rehearsal giving a small glimpse
of what she's gonna bring when she hits
the stage
thank you
[Music]
even though you do your run-throughs
it's still different when you hit the
stage with an audience because there's a
little bit more energy that you have
you're so pumped and so hyped
from
the energy that you get from your
audience the singer also gave a sneak
peek of her dress rehearsals and
pre-show rituals
get in
one two three
[Applause]
that's Janet looking stunning in a bold
orange outfit a blazer with a vest
underneath and matching trousers now
Janet takes her rehearsals pretty
seriously especially when it comes to
new choreography and that commitment is
nothing new she explained her process to
ET nearly 16 years ago when I'm just
coming into dancing from night
having done it in a while
it I like to give myself a good amount
of time especially when you're picking
up a new feel it's just like picking
it's it's it's like okay here's this
choreographer and this is their Style
so it's not just the steps you have to
get the style the feel of the dance to
make it look as they make it look and
then you put your own into it while we
wait patiently to see what Janet brings
for Essence Festival
we'll try to learn
[Music]
foreign